for millions of people around the globe
the Harry Potter book and film series
were the closest they'd ever come to
experiencing actual magic the journey of
the young wizard from an orphan who
lived under the stairs at his cruel
aunt's home into the legendary hero who
defeated the world's darkest villain was
nothing short of epic the final
installment of the story was as complex
as it needed to be to wrap up seven
chapters worth a sorcerer storytelling
so to make sure you caught everything
important at the end let's shed a little
Lumos light on what happened in the
conclusion of the Harry Potter saga what
kid Snape's true side comes through in
the beginning of the final film
Dementors loomed over Hogwarts
Professor Snape observed from on high
how much devastation the Dark Lord's
looming presence had caused his school
but he had to carry on because it was
all part of the plan no one else knew
about see Snape might have seemed like a
terrible person throughout the whole
series but his true loyalties became
clear in his final moments he was
ultimately expelled from school and
killed by Voldemort snake just so the
Dark Lord could take true ownership of
the Elder Wand some friend Baldy was
Harry overheard everything and tried to
rush in and help Snape as soon as you
know who was gone but it was too late
instead Snape used his last moments to
give his least-favorite student of
teardrop full of memories in them Harry
discovered the gut-wrenching backstory
of Snape's unrequited love for Harry's
mother Lily after all this time
[Music]
or as it turned out he'd been crazy
about her since childhood and was also
looking after Harry the whole time by
feigning allegiance to the Dark Lord the
only reason he murdered Dumbledore was
because the headmaster was already dying
and didn't want Draco Malfoy to be
forced to do the deed Snape's open
contempt for Harry at Hogwarts was still
pretty real since he looked so much like
his dad James but he was trying to
protect Harry all the while so he could
fulfill his destiny to defeat the Dark
Lord it probably didn't hurt Snape's
feelings too much that Harry Potter was
always meant to die in his big Battle of
Voldemort though speaking of which no
resurrection stone required
there's a reason Dumbledore had his eye
on Harry Potter from day one and helped
fanned the flames on harry's chosen one
persona in the Wizarding community he
was one of the few people who knew that
Harry was predestined to die in a battle
against Voldemort Harry finally realized
the truth about his fate once he saw
Snape's memories and found out he
himself was the final Horcrux
of Voldemort lives in the side him after
helga hufflepuff's cup was destroyed and
the diadem of Rowena Ravenclaw was done
for Harry left hermione and ron to deal
with the snake while he set off on what
he knew was a suicide mission to face
Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest sir
when the time come
the boy must die
he didn't exactly know what would happen
after that of course but he trusted the
late headmaster enough to follow his
lead even to his own death if necessary
boy come to die upon going gently into
that good night Harry awakened and what
appeared to be a milky white vision of
King's Cross station where he'd hopped
onto platform nine and three-quarters so
many times before
Dumbledore awaited him with the news
that he'd successfully killed off the
part of Voldemort that remained inside
of him in the process of dying so Harry
had a choice to board a train back to
the realm of the living or to just move
on to where he didn't say Harry knowing
his battle wasn't done opted for the
former he left behind the scaly tiny
version of Voldemort that had infected
his mind for so long and used his
perceived death to gain an advantage
Hagrid carried him back to the school
just as an unknowing Voldemort started
bragging about his conquest to garner
new recruits and got an unexpected
surprise the Elder Wand was his all
along no matter how many Horcruxes
hairiness friends successfully destroyed
Voldemort was still a more powerful
wizard than all of them so when Harry
arose from the dead to pick a final
fight with the Dark Lord
he was very quickly overtaken by you
know who but Voldemort still couldn't
kill him with the wand again even after
he'd taken ownership from Snape why well
it turned out that Snape wasn't the one
who'd gained control of the Elder Wand
in the first place so didn't actually
pass to Voldemort upon Snape's execution
while Snape had indeed killed Dumbledore
and taking possession of the wand in
half-blood Prince it was Draco who'd
originally disarmed Dumbledore and thus
received the allegiance of the Elder
Wand then when Harry disarmed him in
their subsequent duel it was Harry who
laid claim to the Elder Wand so while
the Elder Wand was successful used to
strike its master down in the forest
when Harry had surrendered himself to
the Dark Lord he still wasn't disarmed
at the wand in that battle it remained
loyal to Harry instead of Voldemort and
it wasn't the only magical instrument
that came into play to take all snake
face down a key weapon presented itself
the Sword of Gryffindor had been an
instrumental tool in destroying
Horcruxes throughout Harry Potter lore
Dumbledore used it to destroy the gone
family ring
Harry retrieved it from the frozen lake
and Ron used it to destroy the locket
that was causing his buddy so much
mental anguish despite knowing its
powers
Harry offered the sword to Griphook in
exchange
for his help to get them into Bellatrix
Lestrange his vault at Gringotts
Griphook returned to villainy soon after
though and left Harry and his friends in
the lurch by abandoning them in the
vault caverns with no promise to get
them out Hermione always with a clever
idea up her sleeve led the trio to ride
a dungeon bound dragon out of the bank
with Griphook perishing and the fiery
skirmish that ensued the sword then
disappeared from his grip to present
itself to a more worthy pair of hands
later on when Hermione and Ron were back
at Hogwarts trying to learn a guinea
away the sword presented itself to
neville longbottom so he could slice the
snake's head off and deal Voldemort one
last crucial blow as he fought his
ultimate battle with Harry unlike other
similar weapons in the Harry Potter
verse the sword knew no master and
simply chose whoever was worthy estat
the time and few were more worthy than
Neville people died every day they
didn't die in vain
but you will after that the Elder Wand
returned to Harry and left Voldemort
falling to pieces
literally the Deathly Hallows come
together at last there was an
interesting Easter egg contained in
Harry's first shot of the last film as
he mourned Abhi's beach front grave he
looked in a triangular fragment of a
mirror the elf had possessed thanks to
the circular nature of his glasses it
created the symbol of the Deathly
Hallows and the reflection is a link to
how all three elements would eventually
be his as explained in the tale of the
three brothers in the second-to-last
movie the Deathly Hallows consisted of
the Elder Wand the cloak of invisibility
in the resurrection stone when combined
they gave a wizard untold power the
ability to disappear from death's
purview and a means to bring back lost
souls
Voldemort got his hands on one the Elder
Wand while Harry had been casually given
the cloak in his earliest days of
Hogwarts not knowing its strength he
eventually recovered the stone - after
kissing his snitch goodbye with the
intention of sacrificing himself
unlike Voldemort however Harry didn't
aim to use these items for world
domination once he came into possession
of all three instead he snapped the
Elder Wand in half and dropped the
resurrection stone in the Forbidden
Forest to be trampled into the dirt by
his centaur he did keep the cloak for
himself because it had once belonged to
his late father and who'd give up an
invisibility cloak he later passed the
cloak down to his own son James Sirius
Potter in James's younger brother Albus
Severus would later swipe it in the
events of the cursed child speaking of
which the next generation in the
nineteen years ahead epilogue to Deathly
Hallows we met Harry Potter's trio of
children with Ginny Weasley particular
attention was paid to Albus Severus
Potter his second son as he prepared to
board the Hogwarts Express for his start
at the school the boy was contending
with the possibility that he might not
make it into Gryffindor and Harry
consoled him as best he could but to say
that I am at Slytherin house
we'll have gained a wonderful young
wizard little did we know at the time of
this movie's release but this was
ushering in a new generation of
Wizarding journeys which plays out on
the stage and Rowling's Harry Potter and
the cursed child was it all in his head
there's a popular fan theory that
everything that happened to Harry Potter
outside a privet drive was a mental
making of his young abused mind and
Deathly Hallows did little to dispel
that theory in fact the movie seemed to
give a wink to that possibility by
having Harry ask his late professor if
his crazy adventure was all just
happening in his head of course it's
happening inside your head Harry why
should that mean that it's not real
so was the entirety of the Harry Potter
universe fiction coming from the
imagination of a desperate boy who lived
under the stairs and who wished for
something more actually if I think about
it it doesn't seem curious at all thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you